this isn't an ordinary military drill
these troops are practicing for global
rescue missions
they have a week to get set up
then their mobile rescue station has to
be ready for operation
it comprises a walk-in clinic rooms for
a dentist an ophthalmologist and an
x-ray station
twice a year the soldiers practice
building a station like this one on
their base
most of the 1200 military personnel
stationed here are qualified medical
workers
much of the energy for the mobile rescue
station comes from the vase's solar
power array
it produces one hundred twenty thousand
kilowatt hours per year covering about
four percent of the bases power
requirements
i think that because the plant is
located in a visible place it reminds
people daily that power just doesn't
come out of the electric socket
it has to be generated somewhere
that raises people's awareness
the bundesfare base also uses geothermal
energy for heating
30 drill holes 180 meters deep draw heat
from underground
in addition the base has its own heating
plant
it still uses natural gas and heating
oil but at least the furnaces have been
downsized
and the search is on for alternatives
in total the base generates half of the
energy it consumes
money
144 military facilities converting to
renewable energy
in the state of saxony unhealth alone
the government has invested more than
one point six million euros in the
project
the
we accompany each step with a study of
its cost effectiveness
we compare alternatives
for example of supplying the bases and
removing waste and choose the most cost
effective one
the mobile rescue station still runs on
diesel fuel during deployments abroad
for example at the moment in mali
but the bundeswehr is rethinking that as
well it's considering a hybrid unit with
a solar array
that would significantly reduce the need
for diesel fuel